Okay, so welcome back. You've managed to
make it right to the end of the video
series. And let me tell you, that's no
mean feat. You should feel really proud of
yourself that you've got here and give
yourself a little congratulations because
the information that you've seen
throughout the video series, first of all,
it's a hell of a lot of information, but
secondly, it's not easy to learn. It's not
easy to take in.
Even in the professional trading world,
many people who've spent decades trying to
trade, even professionally, still don't
get a lot of the stuff that you've seen.
So if you get to this point and you think
you've got a decent understanding, just
even a decent understanding of what you've
seen throughout the video series, you've
done really well to get that. So you
should definitely congratulate yourself.
But you've got one more job left to do.
You've got to take the exam. And the exam
is a 100 question, multiple choice exam
over 90 minutes, which basically means
you've got 54 seconds per question as a
limit.
And when you take the exam, you'll be
doing it question by question. And there
is only one right answer. You're going to
have choices of A, B, C or D. And there is
only one correct answer. So you can't
choose two. That's the first thing.
Secondly, once you've actually committed
to an answer and you click submit to go to
the next question. Unfortunately, there's
a restriction where you can't go back to a
previous question and change your answer
to that question.
We find this is a lot better in the online
examination process because it really
makes you commit to your answer. And once
you're committed to your answer, it's
better just to move on, especially when
you're facing a time limit. So we just
find it works better.
Now, the exam itself, in terms of grading,
to pass the exam, you have to get 50%. So
if you get between 50 and 60%, that means
you've got to pass grade. If you get
between 60 and 70%, that means you've got
a merit grade. And if you get over 70%,
you get a distinction grade.
So if you do manage to get a distinction
here, it not only means that you've made
it right through the video series, which
is tough in itself, because it's a lot of
information and it's difficult information
to understand.
You've not only done that if you've got a
distinction, but you've also proved to
yourself that you've actually learned
something on this course.
And that's really the primary reason for
this exam. So that you can test yourself
to see if you've actually learned
something here. It's for you guys to
really just test yourself.
The secondary reason for the exam is
essentially for people who have got the
objective of working in the industry to
use this exam mark on your resume.
So once you've taken the exam and you've
got the mark, everyone gets emailed a
certificate and you can put on your resume
the course content with all the buzzwords
of everything that you've learned.
You can put your exam mark and you can put
us, the Institute and me personally, Anton
Creel, as a referee for references on your
resume if your objective is to work in the
industry at some point.
So if you're looking to go and work at a
hedge fund or in some professional trading
capacity in the future, this is the
process that you go through and it's going
to help you a hell of a lot in the
application stage and in interviews.
Because now you actually speak the
language and you understand the approach
of a professional trader.
So we'd encourage you to do that in terms
of references and using the Institute and
me personally as a referee.
Employers will not ask you for references
unless they offer you a job.
So once you've been offered a job, if you
want to get in contact with us through the
contact form on the Institute website and
ask us for the reference, we'll send you a
reference with your exam mark and a full
reference that you took the course and the
mark that you got in the exam.
Okay, so let's go over to the exam.
It's been an absolute pleasure teaching
you the real professional trading
approach.
I do hope to see you on the other side at
the Institute.
However, if you choose to trade anywhere
in the world, that's absolutely fine.
I wish you the best of luck in your
trading objectives.
I hope you're profitable.
You continue to be profitable and you have
a very successful trading career and
trading life.
It's been a pleasure.
Thank you very much and good luck in the
exam.